[Musique]
et antoine phénom a rejoint bon soir
antoine on soir au menu cet original une
hanche fox de plus la pro b 'mid
qu'ovide oui c'est
une info que se baser sur cette vidéo
vous la percevez une courte une courte
vidéo qui a quand même été vue plus de
cent trente neuf mille fois qui est à
l'origine basé sur tik tok alors qu'est
qu'est ce qu'on y va envoyer un homme
qui est en train de de tirer ce qui
ressemble à un mannequin vous voyez sur
sur un lit d'hôpital un mannequin assez
assez bien fait rire début tirs il lui
tire le droit il touche le visage comme
pour nous montrer bien nous que c'est
que c'est un mannequin mais surtout ce
qui est intéressant c'est le commentaire
le petit tweet qui est au dessus tout
est faux alors c'est un peu un peu flou
mais en revanche si l'on va sur un autre
un autre compte twitter là c'est
beaucoup plus clair vous le voyez les
hospitalisations de patients que vite ce
sont des mannequins d'une certaine
manière sous-entendu il n'y a pas ou peu
de patients hospitalisés
duco vide le reste n'est qu'un mensonge
des autorités vous l'aurez donc compris
une rhétorique donc complotistes ça
c'était aux états unis on a retrouvé
cette même vidéo aussi en france j'ai
choisi ce compte là au hasard pour pour
l'illustrer avec les seyssois si un
tweet ou le message est bien clair
regardez ces images à l'esprit la
prochaine fois que vous verrez des
hôpitaux débordés 1 2 patients à la
télévision des mannequins dans les
hôpitaux en lieu et place des passions
qu vide ça transpire quand même la fox a
bah oui effectivement est assez assez
logiquement et pour s'en rendre compte
il suffit de repérer le comte tik tok le
petit hâte que l'on voit en tout petit
ici sur sur la vidéo pour remonter à
l'origine de la séquence au en question
le nom du compte celi l'art à chouiner
on l'a on l'a retrouvée d'une certaine
manière son compte nous apprend et bien
qu'ils les étudiants infirmiers aux
états unis poste régulièrement des
vidéos de lui et de son quotidien au
point qu étudiant infirmier sur tik tok
las une vidéo de lui
de répondait notamment à un autre
utilisateur de tik tok et tigre au
groupe donc des petits extraits de son
quotidien en tant qu'infirmier la
l'utilisateur à l'air choqué voyez ici
demander ce qu'il s'agit vraiment d'une
vraie patiente est donc face au réalisme
de la séquence l'hydre ashwin donc cet
utilisateur a dû du ce se justifier il a
posté une autre vidéo que je vous ai
sélectionné avec ce commentaire vous
livre le contenu juste pour être clair
il dit il s'agit bien d'un maintien
d'exercice donc pas d'une vraie personne
la vidéo a été tournée dans le
laboratoire de l'école et pas dans un
hôpital conclusion qu on retrouve là
encore indret le mécanisme classique
d'une un fox une vidéo originale sortie
de son contexte il faut préciser que la
vidéo d'origine a été légèrement
raccourcie à la fin on voyait ce fameux
livre ashwin donc louis montrait son
école d'infirmier donc voilà de vrais
mannequins mais pour des exercices donc
et dans une école d'infirmier ce qui par
nature vous avez une autre un fox à nous
proposer oui une info que cette fois ci
basée sur un faux tweets de nos
confrères de rfi elle est assez elle a
été assez peu partagés sur les réseaux
sociaux en eux mêmes elle a beaucoup
circulé dans des groupes whatsapp ce
tweet le voit si vous vous l'apercevez
il annonce une soi-disant tentative
d'assassinât visant félix tshisekedi
président de l'ère dessine en croit ce
message le dirigeant est donc été visé
par une attaque au couteau d'une jeune
femme le tweet vous le voyez à l'air
totalement véridique il y mêle il émarge
d'un compte et refi afrique avec la
petite certification bleu qu'on aperçoit
sur twitter
le problème c'est que le renvoi que vous
apercevez voyez ici cette petite ligne
d'url en bas du tweet ne renvoie vers
une page une page d'erreur de premières
incohérences donc et lorsqu'on se penche
sur le fil twitter de rfi pour voir si
ce tweet a bien été a bien été publié
bien on se rend compte qu à la date et à
l'heure à laquelle a été publiée on
retrouve ce petit lac n'a absolument
rien à voir il fait référence à un
défilé de la garde républicaine mais on
retrouve la même photo voilà vous l'avez
compris un faux tweets donc fabriquer
toutes pièces il faut savoir justement
qu'il existe des applications gratuites
qui permettent de falsifier de réaliser
de faux mais sa joie même détruite donc
si vous voulez en apprendre plus jours
renvoie vers l'excellent travail de très
complet sur ce sujet de nos confrères de
l'organe vérification de l'information
congo tchèque merci beaucoup antoine
fenaux merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
demi heure d'information